welcome back I'm not going to do a bunch
of projectile motion problems this cuz I
think you'll learn more just seeing
someone do it and thinking out loud
maybe than all the formulas and I have a
strange notion that I might have done
more harm than good by confusing you
with a lot of what I did in the last
couple of videos so hopefully I can I
could undo any damage if I have done any
or even better hopefully you did learn
from those and we'll just add to the
learning so let's start with both start
with a problem let's just art with a
general problem let's say I'm at the top
of a cliff and I jump so instead of
throwing something I just you know I
just jump off the cliff and you know
what we won't worry about my my motion
from side to side we just assume I go
straight down we could you know you can
even think that someone just dropped me
off of the top of a cliff
I know these these are getting kind of
morbid lit but let's just assume that
nothing bad happens to me so let's say
that at the top of the cliff my velocity
so my initial velocity velocity initial
is going to be zero right because I'm
I'm stationary before the person drops
me or before I jump right and let's say
at the bottom of the cliff my velocity
is let's say it is 100 meters per second
so my question is what is the height of
this cliff so what is and actually you
know what let me let me I think this is
a good time to actually introduce the
the direction notions of velocity that
show you this scalar quantity so let's
just assume up is positive and down is
negative so my velocity is actually 100
meters per second down
I could have assumed the opposite so
velocity the final velocity is a hundred
meters per second down and since we are
saying that down is negative and gravity
is always pulling you down we're going
to say that our acceleration is equal to
gravity which is equal to minus ten
meters per second squared and this is
you know gravity I destroyed that by
ahead of times because when we're
dealing with anything of throwing or
jumping or anything on this planet
we could just use this constant and the
actual number is like 9.81 but I want to
be able to do this without a calculator
so I'll just I'll just stick with minus
10 meters per second squared so it's
pulling me down that's why the minus is
there so my question is okay I know my
initial velocity I know my final
velocity right before I hit the ground
all right when I hit the ground what's
the distance and in this circumstance
what does distance represent distance it
would be the height of the cliff so how
do we figure this out huh well what's
the only formula that we know for
distance well we know that actually it's
really the change in distance but in
this case it's the same thing so change
in distance is equal to the average
velocity and you know when you learned
this in middle school or wherever
probably even elementary school
you didn't say average loss because you
always assume velocity was constant so
the average and the instantaneous
velocity was kind of the same thing but
now since the velocity is changing we're
going to say the average velocity so
just the change in distance is equal to
the average velocity times time and this
should be intuitive to you this at this
point I mean velocity really is just
distance divided by time or actually
change in distance divided by times
change in time change in distance
divided by change in time is velocity so
actually let me change this to change in
time right but since we always assume or
we normally assume that we start a
distance is equal to zero and we assume
that we assume we start at time is equal
to 0 we can write distance is equal to
velocity average times time maybe later
on we'll do situations where we're not
starting at time 0 or distance 0 and in
that case we will have to build more
formal and say it's change in distance
is equal to velocity average velocity
times average times the change in time
sorry I'm messing up all the terminology
anyway this is the formula we know and
so let's see what we can figure out can
we figure out the average velocity well
the average velocity is just the average
of the initial velocity and the final
velocity so the average velocity
is just equal to the average of these
two numbers so minus 100 plus zero over
two I'm just averaging the numbers
equals minus 50 meters per second so we
were able to figure that out
what can we figure out time well we know
also that velocity or let's say the
change in velocity so change in velocity
change in velocity is equal to the final
velocity minus the initial velocity
right nothing nothing fancier this is
you don't have to memorize this this
hopefully is intuitive to you that the
change is just the final velocity minus
initial velocity and then that equals
acceleration times time right so what's
the change in velocity in this situation
well the final velocity is minus 100
meters per second and then the initial
velocity is zero so that equals the
change in velocity is equal to minus 100
meters per second I'm kind of jumping in
and out of the unit's but I think you
get what I'm doing and that equals
acceleration times time well what's the
acceleration it's minus ten meters per
second squared because I'm going
straight down minus ten meters per
second squared times time this is pretty
straightforward equation right divide
both sides by the acceleration by the
minus ten meters per second squared and
you will get time is equal to the
negatives cancel out and as they should
because well write the negative time is
a difficult well we're assuming positive
time and then it's good we got a
positive time answer but the negatives
cancel out and we get time is equal to
ten seconds so there we have it we've
figured out time we figured out the
average velocity so now we could figure
out the height of the cliff the distance
is equal to the average velocity minus
50 meters per second times 10 seconds so
the distance this is going to be an
interesting notion to you the disk
is going to be - 500 - 500 meters so
this might not make a lot of sense to
you what is what is - 500 meters mean
well this is actually right because it's
actually this formula is actually the
change in distance change in distance
right we said if we did formally it
would be their change in distance so if
we have a cliff let me change colors so
that it looks like a cliff so if we have
a cliff and if we assume that we start
that this that this point right here is
distance is equal to zero then the
ground the ground if this if this cliff
is 500 meters high your final distance
so this is the initial distance your
final distance DF is actually going to
be at minus 500 meters right we could
have done it the other way around where
we could said this is plus 500 meters
and then this is zero but all that
matters is really the change in distance
right we're saying from the top of the
cliff to the ground the change in
distance is minus 500 meters and - based
on our convention we said - is down so
the change is 500 meters down and that's
the height of the cliff so that's pretty
interesting if you go to a 500 meter
cliff so that's that's what that's
roughly the size of a let's see 500
meters is about 1,500 feet so that's
that's roughly the size of you know that
may be a very tall skyscraper like the
World Trade Center or the Sears Tower so
if you jump off of something like that
this will be no air resistance which is
a big assumption or let's say if you
were to drop a penny because a penny has
very little air resistance if you were
to drop a penny off of the top of a
Sears Tower or some building like that
at the bottom it will be going 100
meters per second so extremely fast and
that's why you shouldn't be doing it
because that is fast enough to kill
somebody and I don't want to give you
any bad ideas if you're a bad person but
it's just interesting that physics
allows you to solve these types of
problems so in the next presentation I'm
just going to keep doing problems and
and hopefully you'll realize that
everything really just boils down to
average velocity but change in velocity
is acceleration times time and change in
distance is equal to change in is equal
to change in time times average velocity
which we all did or just now so I'll see
in the next presentation